l'île de la Réunion région européenne la
plus au Sud de la planète doit affronter
des handicaps structurels
importants éloignement géographique
relief accentués étroitesse de son
marché intérieur
son inscription à l'objectif convergence
du fait de son ultra périphéricité est
aussi justifié par des défis à relever
répondre d'une part à une forte
progression démographique et d'autre
part à la création soutenu d'emploi dans
un contexte difficile où près de 30 % de
la population est au
chômage l'agriculture représente un
enjeu majeur en matière de développement
durable c'est ce qui a dicté dicte et
dictera notre démarche collective pour
répondre à cet enjeu c'est une
responsabilité qui nous incombe par
devoir envers la population réunionnaise
et par respect pour les partenaires qui
nous soutiennent tel l'État et
l'Europe c'est tout cela qui explique
notre vigilance devant les mesure de pé
générale susceptible de remettre en
cause nos efforts déployés depuis des
décennies dans un cadre
stratégique jamais remise en cause et
réalisé en étroite collaboration avec
les acteurs agricoles les cahiers de
l'agriculture socle du Prade plan
réunionné pour une agriculture durable
vont très bientôt consacrer cette
démarche collective dans un document
dont l'élaboration aura été le fruit du
travail concerté entre l'État et le
département la région et les autres
acteurs
agricoles C orientations majeures ont
été
identifié premièrement la nécessaire
gestion harmonisée du foncier agricole
deuxièmement la consolidation de nos
filière de production agricole
troisièmement la conquête de nouveaux
marchés en jouant sur la qualité des
produit 4èm faire de l'agriculture un
vecteur
de l'innovation et enfin 5ièmement faire
de l'agriculture un vecteur d'emploi et
d'insertion
sociale sur un territoire insulaire
contraint l'agriculture doit garder
toute sa place dans le respect d'une
double exigence préserver
l'environnement avec un parc national
couvrant près de 40 % du territoire
cohabiter avec une zone d'urbanisation
répondant au défis du million
d'habitants à l'horizon
[Musique]
il est primordial que la Réunion
maîtrise son foncier agricole le schéma
d'aménagement régional a fixé un
objectif de 50000 hectares en 2013 nous
en sommes à 43000 hectares ce qui
nécessite pour atteindre ce chiffre de
premièrement freiner l'expansion
urbaine deuxièmement poursuivre la mise
en valeur agricole des terres appelées à
être urbanisées dans dans les années à
venir et enfin troisièmement remettre en
valeur les terres en friche dans les bas
au profit des cultures et dans les hauts
pour l'élevage cette ambition à mon sens
est largement partagée de tous les
acteurs
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la Réunion on a
estimé qu' qu'il y a environ 5000
haectares de terre en friche et
aujourd'hui il faudra à tout prix les
ramener à l'agriculture dans le domaine
de de la canne bien sûr de l'élevage et
aussi de de la diversification maréchè
et autre fruitière ou autre c'est un
besoin aujourd'hui parce que la safè
aujourd'hui on a quand même un terrain
et il y a SEP demandes moi je pense qu'
c'est important de bien mettre en place
un schéma départemental donc de sur la
gestion des matières organiques tant
aussi bien agricole qu'au niveau
industriel parce qu'il faut bien avoir
l'esprit c'est la notion d'optimisation
des surfaces agricoles à la Réunion cet
élément est extrêmement important parce
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à avoir une
gestion cohérente dans les années à
venir de notre agriculture avec un
foncier donc où on aura
[Musique]
optimisé nous devons poursuivre notre
politique de renforcement de la
production locale visant à la
sécurisation alimentaire du département
aujourd'hui on produit plus de 75
% des fruits et légumes frais à la
Réunion près de 100 % de la viande
fraîche dans le porc et la volaille
ainsi que 100 % des œufs frais ce qui
est déjà significatif pour un petit
département insulaire comme le nôtre
mais on doit poursuivre et consolider ce
développement dans le temps les
agriculteurs réunionnés ont bien compris
les les enjeux environnemental et donc
nous avons à la Réunion en tout cas pour
objectif de produire plus de produire
mieux mais bien sûr en respectant le
petit territoire qui est le nôtre pour
faire de sorte que notre environnement
ne souffre pas et et aussi que justement
que nous la préservion puisqu'il s'agit
de transmettre ce patrimoine deain à nos
enfants et à nos petits-
enfants aujourd'hui il faut qu'on arrive
à maintenir notre modèle d'exploitation
agricole familiale diversifié et
développer la complémentarité entre
filières ce modèle va nous permettre
d'installer des jeunes agriculteurs dans
des conditions de réussite
[Musique]
optimal on peut de concurrer de marché
aujourd'hui pour nous c'est cette
conquête passera par une traçabilité de
produits de la qualité pour aller
conquérir tous les marchés existants de
la grande distribution la les
collectivités local la transformation et
toutes les niches où aujourd'hui se vend
le fruits et
légumes on peut partir à la conquête de
N marché diversifier notre offre sur les
marchés export en commençant par
consolider aussi ce qui existe sucr
spéciaux ananas label r l en et en
recherchant de nouvelles niches et de
nouvelles destinations dans notre
environnement régional il s'agit de
poursuivre les efforts entrepris par les
opérateurs économique de l'île de la
réion en matière de reconnaissance de la
qualité et de l'origine de leur produit
aussi bien sur les marchés réionnais
tels que les marché forain le marché
national ou le marché européen en
défendant l'origine
[Musique]
réignantmission principale d'air can
concerne le développement de processus
et des produits innovants pour la
filière CAN et en particulier donc on
est sur le développement de variétal et
de techniquees cultural qui soi adapté à
chaque zone de production et le
développement de nouveaux de nouvelles
valorisations dans le cadre de la chimie
verte et de la bioraaffinerie de la Cann
tout ça s'inscrit bien sûr dans le cadre
du développement durable de la filière
l'armé flore est un institut technique
d'expérimentation et de recherche pour
répondre à une demande professionnelle
pour la mise au point de d'itinéraires
techniques économiquement intéressant
agroécologique sur des produits qui
doivent répondre aux attentes des
consommateurs
régonnais il est évident que la
coopération existe déjà dans un certain
nombre de domaines alors coopération
avec les pays de la COI évidemment mais
on pense qu'il faut dépasser le cadre de
la COI dépasser le cadre de la COI ça
veut dire penser à l'Afrique à l'Afrique
de l'Est et surtout à l'Afrique du Sud
qui est à nos portes on devrait pouvoir
importer des matières que l'on ne
produit pas la réunion des matières
premières et là on ira vers une
coopération gagnant gagnant et je crois
que c'est dans cette voie làà qu'il faut
[Musique]
prospérer la politique régionale de
formation agricole constitue une des
réponses aux défis posés à notre
agriculture
elle est constituée autour de trois
exigences l'accompagnement des
agriculteurs en activité l'installation
de nouvelles exploitations l'élévation
du niveau de
qualification l'objectif étant de former
les compétences locales afin de soutenir
le développement d'une agriculture
durable moderne et
compétitive nous avons donc une réalité
de très petites entreprises agricoles il
faut donc
faciliter les conditions qui seraient
favorbles pour recruter un salarié donc
un groupement d'employeux c'est
plusieurs agriculteurs qui se mettent
ensemble et qui disent on va gérer
administrativement toutes les formalités
liées à l'emploi et en même temps on va
aussi gérer toutes les l'accompagnement
de du public qu'on accueille en les
spécialisant au maximum et en les
rendant en fait beaucoup plus
employables dans nos réalités à nous le
le groupement d'employeur est vraiment
donc pour la réunion un excellent outil
pour favoriser l'emploi salarié dans nos
exploitations a encore quelques mois
j'étais à la recherche d'un emploi et le
fait d'intégrer cette exploitation ça me
permis d'avoir les bases de
l'agriculture pour pouvoir par la suite
pouvoir envisager de continuer dans
l'agriculture dans ce milieul c'est
aussi pour moi la possibilité de pouvoir
inséré
professionnellement l'agriculture
runionnaise a
incontestablement façonné l'histoire de
l'île de la Réunion ses paysages et puis
même l'identité créole et c'est vrai que
le réunionnais est allé conquérir les
haut de l'île nous sommes passés très
vite à une agriculture post-coloniale à
une agriculture développée
avec trois piliers essentiels de
l'agriculture la canne à sucre qui est
qui était la monoc culture phare mais
aujourd'hui également l'élevage et la
diversification maréchère principalement
et fruitière ce sont les trois leviers
essentiels l'Europe nous a beaucoup
accompagné et pareil est un partenaire
incontournable de l'agriculture
réunionnaise au travers les aides
qu'elle apporte aux régions ultra
périphérique en matière agricole au sein
donc de la politique commune agricole la
PAC qui est vé au niveau européen
beaucoup d'emplois dans l'agriculture
ronaise 20000 emplois créés et puis
d'autres induit autant donc qu'il y a je
le crois des marges de progrès encore à
faire dans notre agriculture et je vous
citerai trois exemples la conquête par
exemple de nouveaux marchés en sachant
que la restauration scolaire 250000
repas tous les jours à la réunion nous
pouvons et nous devons gagner sur des
produits locaux des parts de marché dans
l'agriculture rignonaise le deuxième
enjeu qui est important c'est que les
jeunes sont attirés par le milieu
agricole le métier d'agriculteur mais
nous avons un espace contraint à la
réunion sur une île et donc il faut
donner la possibilité à ces jeunes
d'avoir du foncier et ce que nous
faisons au niveau de notre espace
naturel sensible en offrant la
possibilité de s'installer à moindre
coût sur des friches ou des terres
cultivables c'est un enjeu essentiel que
euh euh celui d'avoir du foncier d'en
préserver mais d'en créer d'autres pour
que des jeunes agriculteurs puissent euh
aussi avoir la possibilité de
s'installer puis nous devons également
pour préserver notre île tenir compte de
la fragilité de cet écosystème et de ce
territoire contraint donc il y a à à
concilier agriculture moderne et
préservation d'un environnement qui fait
également la richesse et peu le label de
l'île de la Réunion le label qui a été
validé par l'Unesco sur les haut de de
l'île e à préserver voilà les trois
enjeux qu'il nous faudra avec l'Union
européenne travailler
pour continuer à tracer la route moderne
et l'avenir de l'agriculture
rignionnaise je crois que nous avons un
partenaire vraiment que nous ne voulons
pas perdre l'Union
[Musique]
européenne